laura georges honoré à ben l'ancienne
joueuse de football féminin au paris
saint germain de 2013 à 2017 et est
présente sur le nouveau terrain de ben
portant son nom la footballeuse ne
cachait pas sa fierté j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi j'ai été étonné j'étais
surprise ah et puis après réflexion
après avoir échangé avec le président du
district que je connais des districts
des yvelines j'ai accepté c'est un bel
honneur c'est une belle reconnaissance
pour moi et les membres de ma famille
c'est pas le seul stade qui porte son
film il y en a d'autres le là où ça fait
du sens et que ses deux longues laura
georges donc a fait énormément pour le
football féminin pour cette pratique
pour ces disciplines désirant jouer sur
place toute l'année le fcb n attendait
depuis 20 ans l'arrivée de cette
structure huit cent cinquante mille
euros environ auront été nécessaires
pour créer ce terrain en fibre
synthétique de dernière génération mais
problème de l'opéra c'est que en hiver
une sont pas praticables et que les
clubs des clubs de foot évidemment sont
obligés d'émigrer dans d'autres communes
donc on a décidé une belle frappe au but
c'était dans notre programme n'est pas
longtemps en iran on s'est dit il faut
absolument qu'on trouve une solution est
erratique et violente la meilleure
région la qualité du terrain a été
approuvé par l'ancienne joueuse
internationale c'est un beau terrain de
de qualité donc je suis contente que les
filles du club mais également les jeunes
puissent avoir un terrain de qualité
pour s'entraîner et puis également pour
jouer les week-ends les personnes
présentes sur place espère que ce
nouveau sol synthétique apportera de
nombreux succès au club du vin
[Applaudissements]